alright dude what happened I look like
you saw a ghost
well I had my head down us texting and I
just saw jeans and I was I thought it
was you I was gonna slap your ass really
hard because I thought you were like Ben
no his table yeah it was cat okay I
would write me at you but he got a me to
movement that's exactly right you would
have been me to it immediately
I know it's close that's I say something
cat oh it boy we almost had a problem
they almost slapped right in yeah you
got a strong you got a strong hand I'm
really gonna slap at home to cat what
would you have done I think I would have
been in such shock for the first couple
seconds and just looking you're like I
would have been so embarrassed
Maya but then waited like yeah Amanda
who doesn't know cars at all
I had a black BMW or something and she I
was waiting for her and I watch her come
out of the restaurant and she gets into
a black SUV and she's just sitting there
it's those yours yeah and I'm just
watching her as she's sitting in a black
SUV wait a minute come around and
finally she opens the door she goes and
I step out and she goes she's go up and
down goes what are you doing come on
let's go I go I said no ideas not your
car my car how would you confuse a
[ __ ] black SUV for a [ __ ] a
payment it yeah she just doesn't pay
attention to cars to that degree but
once a truck and ones would call correct
to that different stuff to that degree
be intelligent [ __ ] I don't know that
was different I mean I was like all
right she did it again
oh well the stuffs jumped on a
motorcycle nope this one go back in
motor sound the cars were a lot more
similar and she got in and sat down and
the dude next to her I went what are you
doing in my car that's buddy yeah but
you guys ah and ran out it is weird when
he confused cards dude I was in Palm
Springs mostly you've been a Palm
Springs I know you've been there I have
been to Palm Springs idiot I don't get
it's so hot it's it is so hot like and
it's kind of like Vegas in the desert a
little bit like that's what I say it's
like the answer Phoenix hot I didn't
know what all the commotion was about
well it's a it's kind of a
but low-rent vacation he maybe I don't
know I did I don't get like but if you
go there and just stay in a nice hotel
like you do that in LA do it anyway
there's nowhere to go like you're in the
desert I guess but your ability to do I
guess you're away it's like a two-hour
drive I stay at this old 60s hotel which
is really cool they redid it so it's all
60s vibe yeah which I'm in the sixties
right now so I [ __ ] with it yeah
but if you're just gonna go the I stay
that uh what's it called Parker Parker
yeah great hotel it is it lower rated
though huh I just don't get why people
go out there well I guess it's hot yeah
but there's nothing like cool is so hot
you can't even like if you're out there
in the Sun I guess yeah that's exactly
it's so cool looking though the dis
hotel the Park Hotel was really really
cool but like I'd go there just because
it was a you know I can't get that
anywhere in LA but yeah why would I
Drive two hours to the desert to stay
there like a new hotel yeah and if the
SLS here there's there's all sorts of
[ __ ] cool hotels there I mean you and I
always get it yeah you and I are always
that way out and when it comes to
vacations but but this I was just like
to me and my kid loves hotels and I Todd
told me about this great hotel because
I'm in the sixties right now so you
should drive down there I was like it
but if they only have this specific 60s
hotel where I can't get anywhere else so
do you go down that did they build that
in 60s or galaxies 60 feet yeah okay
twelve twelve reasons all right scroll
down gin let's see let's see if any of
these Seles mid-century modern style all
right
the pool parties okay the food compared
to LA yeah keep moving because I that's
not a reason it's going down there
the aerial tramway hold on which was in
the mountains are sending about yeah ten
minutes there was some nice mountains
all right see you what else have this
whenever I see a big mouth want to get
out and climb it
yeah me too I want to run I want to
charge up it yeah me too I want to
charge up it to work my lab I didn't or
they have that they could have been cool
well no I wish I was on that my son
would I love that yeah that's kind of
cool
okay all right keep going chin so far
I'm so I shoot deer from from from it
you have your rifle and you shoot deer
from it the Living Desert that'd be
reason I don't go there nonprofit zoo
hedgehogs cheetahs she
does camels whoa foxes snacks pet some
very cute I mean snakes snakes
I say snacks because I eat them when I
mean I in the yeah I'm snake eater Robo
lights so far I'm okay so far ah lord
has lights got a with the power this is
reaching out the cocktail yeah that that
you mean just staying hydrated in the
desert but the Parker Hotel did have a
cool bar with like classic like
whiskey's and stuff is gay man yeah okay
again you if I don't go there for that
part do you have sex there Jeff Sachs
there no I didn't man not in the desert
air a hot desert is wrong with you dude
okay
I'm asking kid for good oh okay I
thought hiking how can you hike in that
desert not during the summer there's no
way right there's no weight like again I
saw a high school the football team out
there how you can't hike that even
follow that I don't know you have to
carry a boy there strolling random stuff
art look at the sky check out the sand
breathe so far I'm not that impressed
unwind
okay yeah yeah I drove back at like at
all yeah I know you mean it's the older
crowd I guess they do Coachella there
how the [ __ ] the kids who can stay
outside in that degree Coachella
I don't get it man I don't either but
that hotel was like that because the the
designer that Steven Allen wand it he
goes these days all modern like
buildings and stuff because that's not
Palm Springs is built off like Sinatra
and that vibe so he brought that hotel
vibe to it is cool man Wow is really
cool architectures some [ __ ] man Ola has
a restaurant from the menus to the that
actually looks how I'd like to have my
house there's something really cool
about that I look like open like that
you just mean open or the design I like
all that it's how I design even if you
want your sixties little Jets to be
little weird for you know weird for me
out yeah yeah it's a cool to see I don't
if I'd want to live in the sixties yeah
that design you took maybe have a room
themed of thick these your whole house
yeah might be a little much right tough
yeah
let's I wanna walk around in a row with
a pipe
smokes a pipe anymore I can't tell you
that sighs I love the smell of pie so do
I grab bees to smoke a pipe there's
nothing like it but no one smokes a good
piping huh you don't see them anymore
don't and and my father just has a
vaping with all the peanuts cotton candy
[ __ ] that someone just died from vaping
you know what I heard his person died
adult too old to be vaping yeah and I
got what you get you know better but a
plane to be babe my dad had a lost a
collection of pipes oh man and and they
make beautiful pipes yeah a pipe what
happened to lost art of the pipe I want
to start smoking a [ __ ] pipe do you
know what's interesting as I was
listening to a podcast on nicotine you
know nicotine is actually pretty healthy
for you it's the delivery system that
[ __ ] people really so yeah so with your
chew and nicotine or smoke and nicotine
yeah it's the way it gets delivered in
your system is what causes all these
issues but nicotine the the people who
smoke it delays onset dementia and
Alzheimer's like there's benefits to
nicotine so if you can get a delivery
system or like maybe a spray or like a
dropper when they contain it actually
can do a lot of good well a mass
murderer or Stalin smoked a pipe you can
see down there now you want to put a
little opium in the pipe but if you look
at Stalin down there which one stolen
this one's the guy right there yeah
that's Joseph steely - I am - um maybe
the worst by the way yeah you don't
really see a lot of pipe smoking going
on though no no you don't you don't and
it's high time like getting to an age
where I'm gonna start maybe at 6:00 oh
you know I do it now dude I've always
look at Einstein smoke enough I ever
smoke cigarettes oh no I never did I've
never done I came in at hey listen I
can't either
I can't Hale we mi I can do weed no
giant [ __ ] but the cigarettes
weed the cigarette they get you though
when I do weed smoke I take a little
puff enjoy doing air into it with I do a
Bill Clinton style yeah I just looked a
little in the bay a little bit just a
little bit so friend of mine this
weekend
she sprayed some THC into her mouth and
apparently they found her on they called
911 went to the beach to you
now kind of get rid of it or whatever
just kind of hanging the Sun problem was
she did six sprays of THC and she passed
out or she just couldn't move and she hi
yeah but by the time they found her she
got so [ __ ] burned that they called
9-1-1 and she's still in the hospital
yeah so she'd better his girlfriend she
did it and then stat outside in the Sun
she she I guess she had they had been
partying all night as the story goes how
old is she she's 25 okay they've been
partying and then she but but she didn't
get much sleep
some was up so I'm gonna do some THC so
I can go to sleep goes walking on the
beach gets so high she sits down calmly
come by fall 12 yeah or one she's still
out there not able to move skin was a
bubbling ah skin was a bubbling white
girl yeah she's got darker skin but yeah
white lost the way but apparently
hospital dehydration Sun stroke all
kinds of [ __ ]
so we believe I wouldn't blame that on
the wheel well the THC apparently was so
strong it was so strong that she
couldn't it incapacitated she I've been
that at six braids yeah but it was
enough though that's what I'm saying
yeah yeah but you never know how much is
in there it was probably the equivalent
of you know who the [ __ ] knows Jesus
you're really that high here been like
hot so high that you I couldn't cuz I
was so high I couldn't breathe I
couldn't feel myself breathing and I
panicked I remember in high right I
didn't think I was gonna breathe I'm in
super paranoid yeah
not at my age though well whatever
Rogan has in that weed sometimes one hit
had me done for a good six at all as you
gonna have to pick you okay come rescue
me yeah I had to leave my car at Rogan
studio and come rescue him pick you I
ate a steak and you were making steak
and for some reason I was taking [ __ ]
forever even the way you were opening
this package I was like he's taking a
lot I was secretly getting more and more
annoyed I was like I'm just sitting here
and he's talking and he's taking a long
time to get that steak out of the
[ __ ] wrapper dude you had a whole
system though the way you make your
steak you that barber
yeah man I was the nola did I have to
pick your dumb ass up so you know I was
in the middle making dinner yeah I just
felt like I wasn't given the proper
welcome
nah man you're high I was annoyed I was
making dinner yeah exactly you know
that's like how you and I are it's like
I know think that you're important might
be so close
oh no but I'm not gonna drive I would
never do that it would take seven
minutes but I'm like no I'm never right
real friends don't ask those favors
don't ask me help you move the airport
get the [ __ ] out of my faith that you're
a man do it on your own dude also do get
on yeah so don't give me please never
call me please never call me and tell me
I could be a better friend like because
I'm busy or something you know oh my god
please never deny be friends
they just fade away can't simply can't I
don't hear from Bret anymore yeah sorry
dude well it's just like you know I
didn't feel like you know the last time
we hung out you were wide hey you know
not a trans man no I haven't I haven't
time sir you gotta be there for me even
if I'm half there Wow come on dude yeah
everyone's running their own ring what'd
you do this weekend dude you don't want
to Palm Springs bro there's hot as [ __ ]
watch some football did you stick to
your Kido oh yeah I haven't cheated yet
dude I had one bite of a brownie on
Saturday night because my son but that's
that does the clothes thing I've came to
cheating I just had a muffin a flaxseed
muffin what does that do to me nothing
right you're 60 doesn't matter the 52
pleasers also died for you doesn't
matter you're old you know no now hold
on you look the same no matter what you
do what you do yeah but when I get my
lids tucked and I get on the old test I
can do any of that do that how long I'm
gonna do it as soon as I feel a little
lagging my energy but daddy's got a lot
of energy daddy keeps going daddy does
daddy God did hurt his shoulders a
little bit though you cancel in journal
because I box without warming up and
then I get in my car and I don't warm
down and I and and the trainer who
trains a lot of pro athletes look to me
it goes like this always said as you go
he goes just starting the box again huh
no warm-up at all as usual just getting
in there huh it's just kind of a thing
like that I was like this guy knows
something I don't
I was like yeah you know I just started
slow no I don't well caught up to daddy
at 52 the old shoulder polders gots
painful huh
huh now I got pain here in this area
between my clavicle and my traps so that
air is all bunched up where where I was
like oh I'm spasming what I can't move
my older hitting with a Wayne again I
hit with whoever yeah and then I'm
trying to spar and I'll dumb so now now
here's the thing here's the thing I I
took I took some anti-inflammatories
this is gonna be surprising to you again
is that I resist that stuff let's do
that night I took three [ __ ] advil
all went away I'm like trying to do all
my stretches make it now
I took three advil I'm like oh this is a
this is a miracle
it's all gone oh dude I stay three weeks
I was hurtin I stay about 800 milligrams
ibuprofen every day coz my foot that
plantar fasciitis
yeah no Punk it just will not go away oh
really now say no so it's been here for
how long I'm in tell about six months so
long so ever had it put hiking on
Thursday or I went hiking on Friday yeah
just won't won't go yeah and you but you
take the anti-inflammatories every night
all I do then I rolled it out last night
on like an ice block it helped the any
get that shot in the heel
yeah the cortisone what are you supposed
to do with this [ __ ] what do we know you
know what usually like stretches and
[ __ ] you can do come on Joe Rogan and my
buddy Joe janam or both of whom did the
stem-cell like the real one the cold and
stem cell will cost you a fortune my
buddy Joe Jana Merced and he's a
hard-nosed guy he's I don't know what's
gonna happen I'll try it his shoulders
had hurt for ten years not a pain in his
shoulders and he hasn't had a cold in 12
months I mean and all the other guys and
Rogan said that his the MRI he had a
torn meniscus after stem cells the tears
gone hmm so there might be some real
[ __ ] to this I could put in my well you
just inject it anywhere right yes so you
you I did you get that much maybe we go
to Panama where we take a boy's trip to
Panama I had that offer that guy after
we oh I have to go to Colombia though
Colombia they do in Colombia some guy
for me for free in Arizona in Arizona
Arizona
well no no he lives in Arizona about
stem cells for free but they have to
document it
you go to Columbia I just don't believe
in anything free and now I'm euro
Columbia first of all nothing's ever for
free that's correct
to educate Derek and a son on that
thanks we're on the road and they go
dude tomorrow we set up this guy said we
can come in as restaurant drink is
whiskey for free I went fellas trust me
nothing's for free
nothing well we got there I'll pop a
shop here basically did a two hour
podcast while they eat their free food
I'd sit there and answer all sorts of
questions yeah that's not free that IV
work that ain't free
That's not me you tell your friend in
Arizona that you want to pay and I want
I want Germany or the United States only
because it's more regulated I worry
about loss the public can go to Columbia
okay Papa Columbia
I would love now I'd like to go there
come on bro little stem cells in this
dick hole don't bring daddy to Columbia
Columbia what have you and I call my it
know what the Costa Rica it's only my my
dream your dream corn Rica though cost I
remember yeah daddy I'd leave early
now let me ask you let me ask you this
tsunami of Columbia would your bro would
your girl let you don't say that don't
say that
boy are you saying about Columbia that
don't say a tsunami tsunami and come so
disgusting you're right
alright I apologize okay that's all calm
down we're good you remember when we
went to that bar right poor island yeah
we go to a bar but they warned us oh but
I didn't know we go to up north the guy
goes oh it's a great bar drinks there
we're all like guys there's what I say
when I say when I'm not kidding it
correct my mom when I say six or seven
deep of hookers 670 I went oh hold on
what's going on here six seven deep hold
on hold on yeah you know when you watch
National Geographic Shark Week and they
Chum the water yeah and then it's like
oh mine seven gringos walked into this
bar it was the crazy I've never seen
more [ __ ] in my life here's my
question and they were just grabbing
it was like Lord my question is this
with all those girls
how many guys to those girls go through
in a in a weekend how many just
strangers lots of [ __ ]
I mean God bless I wonder yeah I just
wonder the if you were to do a bacteria
swab on the old dude like it takes that
all right I'm sorry care it just seems
like drinking a cup of God I drink for
laughing from that's a lot of work bro
oh so let me get this straight if
someone has a hose out yeah it's
delicious water yeah anyone's been
drinking through it you don't even have
a sip yeah as long as you don't put your
mouth on the old on the on the on the
nozzle well I like to get my mouth on
the knob yeah come on of the test you
passed it with flying [ __ ] your bacteria
do Columbia Columbia I'm just worried
about my safety that's my papa sticks
out I don't know you you fit in your
hapa stick so they would know who you
are I'm a big boy you like the drug
lords would respect you because you're a
fighter and stuff also Columbia's got
you know that could be some problems
take me for ransom mmm I'd [ __ ] break
you out what oh I don't break yeah I
didn't you you when you want us Safari
did you go to Serengeti
no that's in Kenya actually Tanzania
can't it's in Tanzania dude yeah I think
it's on the board of cancer Kings hands
than me Oh bro I've been looking at
going Serengeti I've been there on my
choice I'm not going well I've been
watching a show on Discovery called
Serengeti it's amazing I've been there
twice
it just was incredible and my my yes and
my family went there and they loved it
loved it very cold in the morning by the
way can get very cold in the morning
just chilly there go ahead and bring it
down jacket and oh we haven't been on a
trip in forever okay the two of us we
really should it's kind of crazy it's a
bummer that we haven't I think we
deserve it
well we're going to NorCal this Saturday
let's not vacation though is it that's
what this so let's go to [ __ ] eat
deli or something that's going on dude
dude dude dude hey hey hey hey way too
far what do you talk about what if what
if we set up some comedy shows in Hawaii
ah
dude Italy let's do that Italy I could
have Justin setup all right
I don't feel have a market in Hawaii
well we do we do we have a market in
white dress up is mallanna I also think
that yes we could dress up as Mauro you
dress more oh no all just don't go on
one girl dress up isn't a little bird oh
all right get me a little tail make sure
the on my butt tail yeah that could be
ass dude that's a great idea
you're I'm the girl and really got
burned yeah you're the bird you mean the
chicken yeah the chicken the gum chicken
I'm honest don't see Dom though oh yes I
mean like if I can just I'll be that
you're welcome you're welcome
I want to be the girl maybe the girl hmm
the Wiggy piggy God Polynesians are hot
in China hey the gals are the gals are
also big-boned gals not all of them dude
you get a mix so make some accidents but
the pure Polynesian woman is a beautiful
woman but a bit but I'm a little light
in the ask for the I've been to Fiji in
those places and they're there some of
them are just pineapple beautiful women
everywhere depending on where you're
from it doesn't matter
oh you right everywhere else huh Oh
who's the thick emic fixer the second
end yes what is happening how did she
get a job well mark hunt with a wig on
what is it I said those are big hips a
lot of power in the hips that's a bet
she's got a lot of punching power that's
a big clap jacked it flapjack mm-hmm
yeah that's head mm-hmm hot mamas first
Polynesian woman to pose for sports
who's the hitter in the back though yeah
that's good plus-size models come on
with the dude oh yeah she's got pierced
nips she does I bet she's a freak nips
are all pierced no nips got flowers very
pretty face mmm
strong face so you get to be a plus-size
model that it's all about the face my
father complimenting a woman one time I
was a young man
ever forget this he goes you're not a
pretty woman he goes he's not a pretty
woman you're a handsome though you're
what I would call a handsome woman well
that's the words I remember going like
this I remember Heidi I was like I go I
disagree I disagree I think you're
pretty I was trying to figure it out she
was looking at on my bed it goes I think
it's a very good compliment I can't earn
more than some woman your words have a
strong presence out like you are the
[ __ ] worst the worst thing gets a
dough it's the worst thing a woman yeah
that's like saying - dude you're cute no
guy once we call cute yeah you're not is
the word yeah you're your proportion
that's that's why or like if a girl if
you do you think he's hot and he girls
he's cute yeah oh god that is a terrible
compliment no somebody can say one thing
to you when you're in high school and it
will [ __ ] you up for the rest of your
life girl I know is beautiful my chin
type in handsome woman just to see let's
see let's see strong jaw lines yeah I
would agree there you go I think she's
so hot she's handsome you [ __ ] she's hot
I know Hansen's not a good term no hands
apparently just means you have a thick
chin yeah yeah Kate Blanchette is
beautiful it doesn't make sense yeah
yeah just like a strong I think
Sigourney Weaver's water-air every bit
of six seven and she tends to be a big
girl avatar bro yeah yeah what
retirement though can't say guys cute
that's never good tuna that's what I'm
too cute I remember girl in high school
Ryan's cute too small to be gorgeous
he's cute I was like man shame off um
yeah you don't be called cute who's that
guy that's another bad term what's up oh
wow yeah let's gather mix our coffee
that's a guy
let's get we get our coffee look at that
guy with his [ __ ] mouth and those
eyes so we get our coffee dude get on
estrogen immediately you were born with
a the wrong face that's a girl head it's
on a guy body congratulations very
Melania Trump looking eyes yeah yeah
yeah there's definitely some Asian a
touch of
in there oh I agent in there they killed
the almond eyes those are some wide eyes
huh I'll tell you watching at the Palm
Springs uh outlets a lot of Asians dude
they love outlets yeah yeah yeah yeah
they like this and that there's a Gucci
outlet their line would like you
Disneyland line yeah just packed mm-hmm
there's love outlets they do my parents
love outlets and IRAs being becoming
very Chinese they're buying up a lot of
Wow Australia's various Chinese
yeah well root they were to his chin
they were rude but they didn't mean to
be rude but they're rude that's cuz
there's packed in so many people they
just got a move man it's like a school
of fish they don't mean to be rude but
you when you grow when when you have
that many people in you know and plus
it's a history where there wasn't really
enough to go around so you
yeah what's doing 19 so change your ways
yeah I know yeah it's frustrating yeah
buses when they like jam um in mm-hmm
well I've been to China and yeah it's
it's not it's not a lot of and the food
when you have to feed that many people
you know you eat everything the food is
it's a remarkable feat that they're able
to feed that many people but it's it's
gonna be on an assembly line it's not
it's gonna be tough
do you see Brazil's on fire yes straight
up on that slash-and-burn right is that
is that because they they burn they but
they burn it because it would take
everyone crazy and land the other cattle
that's what happens and I they're doing
all the time yeah and you know they
supply its supplies 20% of the Earth's
oxygen apparently apparently the oxygen
is rican sumed by the animals and the
ecosystem within the forest but we don't
want that [ __ ] burning I I mean Jesus
you know it's crazy there's a fire going
on right now in LA to Eagle Rock
is that like Glendale yeah Glendale how
bad is it
uh I saw yesterday on my way home pretty
bad is it bad it's still going on right
now [ __ ] I don't know that it's mostly
under wraps but still burned dude how
bout yesterday I get home from Palm
Springs relaxing in my undies
like I should a C's Blair and I see
there's a potential active shooter to
ping them all which is the mall I always
hang out at should I freaked out I text
rogue oh dude you see this active
shooter just yeah I think it might be a
robbery so there's like all this info
the news if they're so far behind the
news like active shooter may be a to
paying them all you should go to Twitter
it's like instantaneous your Twitter for
news and it's like not active shooter
two robbers both both they fired shots
Neiman Marcus were apprehended I wait
for the news the news 20 minutes later
gets it breaking news I'm like Jesus
crowd who's dumb enough to rob a mall
well they were successful last week and
they came back with more people and it's
a when they caught us cashing grab so -
and grab so Thank You Brad smash and
grab
so they Jack Marcus for the jewelry nope
purses Oh purses yeah play it play that
tap to pay him all panic we're in panic
cuz there's helicopters everywhere else
I got [ __ ] getting sad alarmed up agenda
Westfield Topanga mall in Canoga Park
it said shoppers running and screaming
it happened inside the Neiman Marcus
there this is Marcus at first many
people reported hearing shots being
fired that caused mass chaos there mass
panic but police were certain that no
shots were fired some cruises several
people who were inside the mall at the
time there was teenagers mothers and
children running strollers children sang
shooter on their daddy's arms when they
evacuated it's like I'm shaking a little
bit because he saw the food everywhere
like people sandals left behind like it
was scary chaos we were just freaking
out and then I just it's one of those
things that you hear on the TV and then
you never think it happens and then when
you're that situation your nerves just
hit you just frightening they'd like to
find a corner with a gun and just wait
that'd be me but then I get shot by the
cops my buddy my buddy did teach his
SWAT teams all I guess no idea if you
have a gun in your in a situation how
you pull it out and now you're waiting
you know to protect yourself what
happens is the cops don't know that and
they see you with a gun they shoot you
they don't know then I can't wait yeah
yeah two people were arrested smash and
grab robberies and sharp objects
of property but I guess they did it
before and one of the security guards at
the mall was like oh I recognize that
guy and that's how they figured it out
oh there was one you know those rappers
they go to a special jeweler that just
happened recently a word they just did
in broad daylight they just came in fast
and took all this crap and all like the
bloody fancy chains fancy dive she's a
pink Panther's have you seen this group
I see no you're right they've gotten
away with a billion dollars every column
yet right they're incredible Dan by the
way when they caught one they've every
time they catch him they break him out
of jail they'll throw a bunch of
weaponry oh and bolt cutters over the
fence catapulted over and those
[ __ ] grabbing they're the
baddest group of and they thought they
were Special Forces guys just a bunch of
kids that grew up in a war-torn Serbian
you know each other bring up bring up
video of them doing that it there they
they study them because they're so
and I think DiCaprio is gonna do a movie
about this from right here they're so
good at at basically figuring out all
option damn they have a logo named after
the pink Panther's Pink Panther series
of crime common feels the pink
commanders name given by Interpol to
international jewel thief Network
consists of 200 to 250 members from very
multi Negro Croatia Bosnia Wow
there's such badasses and and and
they're rough but they've never killed
anybody
well they'll [ __ ] with the you know all
arias was in prison now though yeah
they've caught not all of them some of
them you can't you can't get away with
it for too long but in Tokyo they got
away with five hundred million dollars
whether I mean it's crazy five hundred
million it's like dude I mean they did
it in they brought a lot in Kardashian
in in Monaco no that was a different
thing in Monaco these [ __ ] guys came
in they have video they actually have
YouTube videos
there's scroll out chin yeah there it is
annex Pink Panther on his little crew
blamed for robbing there you go Kim
credit oh she got rapped robbed in a
friend oh that one I may do some
highlight happy was high level because
they were involved with the security
with Kim Kardashian
so she got you know wrote robbed at
gunpoint there they're really gutsy but
on YouTube you'll see them doing she
held her at gun
stole nine million children in the
middle of Monaco in Monaco like they
break in they steal you know 100 million
dollars worth of jewelry and get on
speedboats and Rider and drive away and
speedboats and each heist would cost
them about a hundred thousand dollars to
get all the equipment and everything
organized and every single one of them
had to rely on each other so that's why
they were so good 400 members one boss
Jesus is there it good go to youtube
they've studied how they do it so
quickly they just will are we allowed to
show that though not really but we can
check it out look at it be and it's
gonna be boring for the people yeah it's
just them stealing stuff and watch the
top one yeah sure it's compilation they
ride right drive right through huh that
looks like a movie got see [ __ ]
think about how much fun this would be
to live on the edge like this you like
this [ __ ] huh I'm actually it's just so
hopefully I did that and present get a
job that's pretty good it's pretty
impressive when they get away with a
billion dollars worth of tools and
they're doing it more for the [ __ ] an
excitement of it all with assault rifles
oh yeah they don't [ __ ] around this is
movie [ __ ] dude yeah I mean they made
the talent job you know Mark Wahlberg
yeah these guys the real Italian drop
stuff yeah I think that what is yeah you
and I should make a lot of money and
just go buy those tools it's much easier
to just go and buy them here you go your
credit you take credit card you're a
smart guy you think they'd figure out a
way to make money illegal ways I think
that they that they ask them of that I
mean a lot of them were just they grew
up in a war-torn country and saw a lot
of violence and we're like you know [ __ ]
it you know it's five hundred twenty
years eight hundred core members biggest
European art heist ever hundred sixty
three million yeah damn three hours
seventy robberies in 35 countries damn
it now that's organized but they cut the
head one huh
I remember in New York there was a group
of Russians or they didn't know who they
were and they were they were taking they
would come in they'd break in that go to
an ATM machine and sawed it in half with
these special saws
murder like that and then just
take all the money you know some people
do some crazy [ __ ] IV in and out in
three minutes and and possible to catch
him we talked about a few weeks ago on
here that they were Irish where they had
the crane yeah Carolyn duck him just
picked it up drop the ATM machine in the
car and drove off it destroyed the whole
side of that whatever that building they
didn't catch him right
I don't think so yeah yeah sometimes you
do what you gotta do they stole that
crane too in the first place yeah so you
slow that to steal can't really buy a
crane it's most bank robberies though
you're only getting like two three
thousand dollars you know that yeah
Google that already lab average bank
robber already laying retire three grand
a 4-game here Artie Lange story when he
was 17 yeah he goes this is gonna be fun
ease with his girlfriend he goes he
writes a notice and the note says I have
a gun give me all your money and the
woman was like he was joking around a
woman gives him all this money his ID so
they catch him
the they go to his house and the the
judge is like let's read this note I
have a gun a gun and you thought this
was funny anything [ __ ] ours I guess
sorry your honor he's this great well
you're doing community service Bradley
gave them yeah that's not bad
17 yeah this day and age though you'd be
in trouble here it is that was brain
robbery netted about $4,300 Wow compared
to an average of 1,500 for all
commercial robberies
although and in green stores that
mistake is similar $60.00 got a lot of
bank robberies though look there you go
average bank robbery in England $31,000
I mean so you didn't rob one yeah you
pay the bills man you have two key
problem oh you gotta keep robbing if you
think of the movies you robbed you're
set for life right now you gotta keep
doing it keep doing how hard is get away
with one yeah bank crime statistic yeah
man it's not I met her a real life bank
robber who through a mutual friend of
ours and he he was looking at a 35-year
bid and in Boston it's a famous case
the prosecutor or the DA or the
scientists in the forensics lab was
fudging data and they threw all the
gazes away and he got a second chance
lucky he was a career bank robber whose
bank you know you know the town that
movie yeah one of those guys met healthy
madam spend time with him yes spend some
time with him he and his partner who did
a lot of it very nice guys just let me
take some serious risks damn look at
that so number of like when it goes to
race so I mean there were some females
but 1200 and what year is this 2018 2018
12 face it well Basie 1300 almost even
1300 white guys 1,300 black guys oh it's
all men
I mean death row is all men the violent
criminals are about 200 female yeah it's
just it they're usually brought in by
the men because they're dating them it's
not women it's like so funny when they
always talk about gender equality okay
how about death row let's see what we
can do about equating that men are
naturally more aggressive and violent
it's a physical thing it's not I've
never been a female serial killer act
there was actually more on and certainly
more monsters but yeah but overall
you're right it's it's a it's a male
phenomenon oh yeah and so no this exit
are not equal noise and women nor would
you know Asian women zero to polite yeah
to polite I feel like cat could rob a
bank though you're pretty gangster I
mean well I think what Asian people have
is that they stay under the radar like
no one really suspects them I used to
joke around with my friends all the time
because I could get prescriptions for
things because of my mental health and
just sell them to these rich kids who
are partying anyways and no one would
ever suspect me no I wouldn't the United
States say if you're embezzling money
from us you'd be the last
I think chin was the United States money
the United States last rose up big then
I know that the United States and Israel
that's the only two that I know do use
female assassins your female you know
yeah people if so if you go somewhere
and you need to not come out of that
place
they I feel like it's a bad idea though
cuz
I'd rather have chin as that well he
looks like an assassin but cat you'd be
drawn through right away you know but
you don't expect a woman to kill you so
that that hostage situation in Thailand
blew my mind I watched it over and over
on oh we've got that bit yeah yeah and
she just I don't know where I was like
where'd she come from
and just kills him the seven dailies
female assassins in history because this
asian woman at bottom right come on up
who are these happening oh yeah they're
all you ever kill Jonas Brothers or some
[ __ ] right that's a woman who did that
yeah who they just like tossed powder in
his faith they covered it in his face is
mouthing died hmm Oh Asian why he's all
agents okay after she come VIN was
murdered by a warlord okay this is hard
not how you get the fright this is
[ __ ]
who's this la tigresa little sexual
prowess so she was a ho that was one of
the women in basque independence just
once before a bomber killed 12 civilian
guards five more cities policeman before
shooting tallies include killing most
wanted terrorists Wow seduced policeman
before shooting their colleagues and
quickly became one unless you're
sentenced to more than 1500 years in
prison kicked out the EPA pledging for
actions right this is just what what hmm
yeah I don't know but the guy that was
killed by this woman she okay Kim that's
a Korean 50 North mother a to mass
murder at age 19 she hadn't been good
from University keep going North Korean
agent
change for six years Wow well there you
go
well maybe they don't take down a South
Korean airliner placed a bomb in the
overhead compartments right for a
disembarkment plane himself during a
stopover the bomb detonating all 150 on
board its captured and confessed she
said death in 1989 but president wrote a
will pardon her she's now married to a
former self
intelligence Africa has two children
after defecting now lives in fear of
revenge from Pyongyang yeah you didn't
get away why'd you get pardon that's
[ __ ] crazy probably cuz she was
forced to do it or something huh maybe
they're not bored they just get old hmm
it'd just be crazy dude yeah man some
people will do it if you have a reason
do you have an ideology that you truly
believe in then cracking a couple of
eggs to make an omelet as they say isn't
ain't no big deal the film Anthon
everybody justifies the the means
justify the end Isis all that stuff yeah
as opposed to the end doesn't justify
the means so kill kill in that logic
goes kill and people use it all the time
and still use it kill three thousand
people to save three hundred thousand
people tomorrow you do that math yeah
and it's a hard math to get out of
sometimes it's exactly like the debate
we had torture torture works to an
extent people say it doesn't and if it
works in getting somebody to tell us
where a bomb is to save other lives the
bigger question is we know that we don't
use torture it's called cruel and
unusual punishment now will you how do
you get around that how do you get
around that
you know you've gots to cat you were
saying you were getting pre-shift from
mental health oh no I click depressions
and like antidepressants yeah cuz I went
to a doctor and he tried to prescribe me
some medicine and I told him that I
didn't want to take anything so but as a
college student [ __ ] gets hard USC
basically Rob's kids for everything they
got I was like hmm couldn't really get
away with selling xanax to kids yeah
nice slide hustle this I don't think
anyone would ever think that I was
selling it's a scam the amount of money
that colleges charge is a scam it's
[ __ ] then you major in what you
understand is communication and ilysm
you're not getting [ __ ] a job just the
thousands of them enjoy that for the
rest of your life
[ __ ] you it's a scam Sutter secure the
American educational system is such a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
better education online I mean they did
your charging so much before
administrative fees and everything for
what it's kind of like you're going to
universities for the networking that's
exactly right it's all this but build a
real usable skill and you'll come out
and you'll get a job like you're really
good at something otherwise I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing now if my kid
wants to major in communications or
gender studies don't waste your time I'm
not do you know I'm not paying I'm not
paying a hundred thousand dollars Covino
goody Community Co but doctors
definitely huh think about in debt
doctors are though I know but I may I'd
also by the time but by the time let's
say you had kids chin by time he's of
age to perform those procedures most
robots gonna be doing it so they think
for kids the matron like that specific
like surgery something they see
technologies you know out out one of the
more I heard saying so a lot cuz I don't
major in this this food is banking on
the future this former admissions
officer at Harvard I think our it was
yeah she was saying that Harvard is it's
such a scam because a lot of black kids
who get admitted to Harvard Harvard
wants to diversify a lot of those black
kids who are very intelligent but come
from a high school that didn't get them
as prepared as say an Asian kid who had
you know a whole different like they by
the time they come to medical school or
pre-med they're so advanced and a lot of
the kids that come who are very gifted
who might be black but come from a high
school didn't prepare them as well
Harvard lets him in anyway knowing
there's no way they're gonna complete
their studies they didn't they're not
gonna be like Eli because they didn't
did it's like going into a class full of
black pulse I just haven't had the
benefit of that schooling and and the
like for 12 years and so Harvard knows
that come in you're coming in to be a
doctor
so you're a black student you have a
dropout or you have to transfer and you
have to get a softer science degree like
Gender Studies or whatever then you're
in debt you come out of Harvard and you
have no you have no transferable skill
and they were talking about this over
and over again it's a [ __ ] I mean I
look I don't know what Harvard does
about it to diversify but it's a problem
all the way around and how about the
fact that our Harvard that you know that
class-action suit there's so many Asians
that get in so many and harbors like
we're gonna have it's gonna be an Asian
college these these kids are
these with their Tiger moms they're so
they're so advanced they plant
instrument fluently and everything else
yeah those schools but that top echelon
schools like and because you're
competing with the world all University
of California's yeah base always always
the agents I know because you're
competing because people from other
countries like China want an American
education then they go back to China so
now your chance of getting into Harvard
if you're a real if you're a white
student with really good grades used to
be twenty percent now your chances are
getting in are three percent cuz you're
you're competing globally that there are
a lot of other good schools day men it's
just competition yeah we do get smarter
that's it I agree with you I agree I
don't give a [ __ ] I still may agree if
you go somewhere else
compete or go to somewhere else I don't
care even kids are taking over they
focus on grades and college and chick
well the Chinese they say the Chinese
are that's a deliberate thing where the
Chinese are basically coming in getting
an education with us working for
companies learn earning that stuff and
going back to China taking all that [ __ ]
with them so because they don't know how
they don't innovate the way we do um
electronically they do though yeah I'm
just saying maybe we need some [ __ ]
quotas you know I'm saying
Chinese from the mainland
I got it easy yes I pledge allegiance
and stay in my country for at least 15
[ __ ] years don't be taking all
actually attacking it man that is a
deliberate program the Chinese are the
Chinese government is not our friend
please understand that everybody yeah
I'll say it my miss what nothing dude
yeah China doesn't play fair on the
global market dude so [ __ ] you hey you
know what [ __ ] off Chinese government
yeah China I don't like the Chinese
government they're oppressive they're
kind of hot today dude yeah I am and
they're and they practice massive theft
from the US brain trust
they're they're thieves they're [ __ ]
thieves how about that anybody else and
who what what no it's all you guys I'm
sorry
you go back to once you got a China dude
yeah I've had a dude
[ __ ] chicken shits even thing you
know David dude what's going on oh I'm
an American I'm an American of course
they do buy a lot of our [ __ ] so we kind
of meet each other are you following the
protests at all Hong Kong
yeah I didn't violent yeah yeah just
watch what the Chinese government does
don't tell their crush them we're gonna
kill everybody yeah
you shoot everybody's now just getting
violent
yeah right see how they get violent
before this point did it process a lot
though China was shut down the airports
yeah yeah for everybody the trivia Hong
Kong belonged to was was leased by
Britain thank you British essentially a
British colony and then went back to the
mainland after the hundred year or so
well know that we've lost all our
Chinese business let's go Chinese people
I hope to they don't like the ladies guy
you do they're an oppressive bunch of
[ __ ] and they don't tolerate
dissent they don't dude all right so
when it comes to brushing your teeth if
you're still using an old toothbrush
you're doing then why don't you leech
when you're sick you know I'm saying
like what are you doing man do you
amputate your leg when you have an
infection or do you take antibiotics do
you take a horse to work do you take a
horse you were if you say yes to all
these things then you're doing it wrong
yeah and quip is not for you but if
you're into brushing your teeth
effectively and with technology time
sonic vibrations they cover the basic ok
takes to everything your mouth everybody
about eight minutes two minutes me but I
have yellow teeth that's when we
wouldn't if we had this device it's a
mirror mount puts brushing front and
center in your bathroom
so you remember to bookend the day using
your new here's my prom be I need that
sensitive sonic vibration in my mouth
because I brush way too hard oh dude
built-in two-minute timer pulses every
30 seconds huh
so I want to switch it up ha ding and up
to 90% of the us a and just people in
general don't brush for a full two
minutes they don't know it's whale oh no
no I don't know
dude I don't know brush heads are
automatically delivered to your door
scheduled every three months for just $5
it's a friendly reminder when it's time
for a refresh so your teeth stay fresh
they got kids brush kid got it all man
kids are the best we do love it because
our families use it our teeth would be
way wider if we use it like it equipment
yes love it that's why we love quip and
why it's the perfect gift for getting
back into the routine quip starts at
just $25 if you go to get quip calm
that's GE t qu IP comm slash fighter
right now you can get your first refill
pack vote free mm-hmm hey Brennan the
number one best overall mattress pick in
2019 by GQ and Wired magazine and CNN
yeah bro
okay you know what that is helix helix
helix sleep comm slash fighter you take
there two minutes sleep quiz it'll match
you with the perfect match your side
sleeper sleeper plush or firm bed
they've got all kinds of things it's
it's customed to your body best sleep of
your life in four couples you can even
split the mattress right down the middle
down so you both get what you're looking
I love it they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free they even pick it up
free if you don't love it which but I
think you will yeah I think you will
$125 off all matched orders for our
listeners at helix sleep comm slash
fighter that's helix h e li x sleep calm
slash fighter for up to a hundred and
twenty five dollars off your mattress
order today are impulsive good night
sweet prince to lighten up the mood I
love this please do
we saw the season what is this anyways
you guys don't know he's a dance
it's just Burt [ __ ] British great
[ __ ] alright
not only athletic he's got a great golf
swing and he can dance he can dance
alone why are gonna work out together
tomorrow
nice this is phenomenal by the way I
wish Burton her would a dance
side-by-sides
it's so great where did he get tearaway
pants from in 2019 oh it's coming back
look at least one smart say what man I
don't as far as marketing Jean I don't
know anyone better than Burt genius
that's great there's no one better than
Burt his marketing that great I love it
God it was good speaking of which this
Wednesday bill burr Bryan Callen Chris
D'Elia Brendan Schaub and Friends
this Wednesday laughs factory starting
at 9:45 Oh Late Show
yeah Late Show come come it's for
charity come one come all it's gonna be
a sick show it's just a second good
laughter factory building we have Martin
making a graphic yeah I got Mark Martin
yep and Laugh Factory is making a
graphic as well for their blast it's
gonna be it's gonna be awesome how
Martin make it laugh actors and use like
a picture for me from MADtv yes Martin's
Martin's I don't have me like this have
you in like a clear Conrad TV you and
your underwear
bloody face broken no really come see oh
there's a picture of you against like
they superimpose your face fighting and
you're all full of blood and your head
it was like one of your awful fights
where you're just literally faces a mask
of blood you'd have your pretty I was
like laughs key what I'll [ __ ] I don't
think so because I was at that fight I
was a light fight that that or crow cup
the crow caws crow blood it was [ __ ]
up I was like oh my god what a way to
make a living oh my the misery I just
knowing you so well now that I mean you
were younger but I mean I don't know
what your mindset was you must have been
like well I got to get win the
championship if I believe I'll lead with
my face here you know dude oh ho
what did they photoshop though what do
you mean don't please don't search he's
up against somebody some days I can't
maybe Rogan they're sleazy [ __ ] know
what it was speaking of you've seen it
shop stupid thing it's doing 19 what
else get this she showed me earlier this
surpassing NFL on Instagram I thought
this is a big deal because well it's
kind of surprising this kind of just
kiss how [ __ ] big the NFL is I mean
then it felt so big yeah UFC past them
but also it kind of makes sense because
I didn't read article but
UFC it's a young age now I'm just six
males and they're so social media savvy
so they're gonna be more willing because
like if every NFL fan not an Instagram
NFL would completely annihilate the UFC
but they don't how did this steep a core
me fight to pay-per-view yeah I don't do
how I saw the prelims it was six and it
was a bottom six out of the 80s piant
and limbs not great yeah hmm so let's
see the UCS 70 million are the NBA has
40 million so there's all yeah this is
the total for all of them but then you
see here NFL 14.9 UFC 15 and the NBA is
just like boom and big but here's the
thing
and be a younger demo the more kids are
on there they always post cool dunks and
highlights like the NBA's a younger kids
game NFL old or right you know the other
day Chris Bosh really good guy really
really nice guy oh it's a basketball
player
yeah yes it was at my house one of my
co-stars so tall what are you I'm just
hanging out my friend Chris boxers Chris
Bosh was here do you want to say hi just
hang a 16 knows no see Jim yes either
you have to retire from a issue in is
like Oh 611 six like yeah you know
insane go back to that thing no chin um
[Music]
15mph 14 mil yeah then base kicking
their ass MLB nine close again older
game yeah Wow
that's not surprising I don't think it
means that much either
you know it's not like Oh UFC is taking
over
look at MLB older game five million Lea
NHL three million that's terrible I
wonder what the NFL's gonna do to
attract the younger audience because
because now like kids growing up there's
so much emphasis on brain trauma and CT
well we should talk about
what's-his-name retiring Andrew Luck
yeah I mean you know that that eight
seven seasons though well he's 29 still
has a I mean Drew Brees is 40 Tom
Brady's 42 but football quarterbacks are
playing longer than ever this
guys so gifted but it's very interesting
that he would do this
he was an architecture major from
Stanford very smart Stanford yes like my
boy Pat McAfee was like smartest guy
I've ever I have no doubt yeah and also
though I was looking at his injuries uh
a lacerated kidney for meth yeah I mean
and also you have you know that's really
deliver what yeah [ __ ] yeah and then
cartilage ripped from his you know and
then obviously leg he had a major leg
injury he had a lot of injuries crazy
yeah out for a whole season with the
shoulder hmm so I mean after a while
you're like yeah in my head [ __ ] this
I wonder if you're gonna see more of
this you could have made a hundreds of
millions dollars more they say but once
you're okay so torn college cartilage
and two ribs parts a torn abdomen
lacerated kidney at least one concussion
torn labrum and mysterious calf ankle
issues
to be honest not bad standard not bad
no there's guys wait way worse than this
that's not I mean I guess what I'm
saying is a torn labrum is doing
shoulder for a core back sucks but
there's been way worse but but if you
have nothing major on but if you have if
you have options if you have options
like he does as in architecture major as
in as in a hundred million dollars in
the bank I can understand how
hundred-percent right because also
remember when he was drafted that was
when first picks got paid but then all
the vets like this isn't fair they're
getting paid more than you know veterans
and guys threw me to up forever so they
now they're there's only a standard
minimum or maximum that guys need paid
but ok so sadly the contract he know him
and Cam Newton were like the last ones
who really got paid his first-round
picks yeah he got a hundred million
dollar contract or some crazy amount so
signed a five-year hundred twenty two
million dollar contract you set to earn
a salary of nine million to nineteen
roster bonus twelve million yeah but so
he signed that to I'm sixteen so he
served three years of that they'll
scroll down cuz his rookie contract he
got a guarantee just quote on it um
maybe I wonder how about this
because oh the hon so look signed a
five-year hundred twenty two hundred uh
contract you said during a base salary
of nine roster bonus of twelve yeah so
he's not gonna see that money he's gonna
see some of it but typing Andrew Luck
rookie contract that was that what that
would be the money that he had typing
Cooke rookie contract yeah Andrew Luck
rookie contract because that that one
hundred twenty two million dollar
contract he's not gonna the only served
I think two years of that luck signed
four-year deal Colts were twenty two
million twenty twelve twenty twelve so
he has that smart guy with his money
doesn't live crazy
I wonder why signing bonus was so you
know yeah hey probably gave up on a
million dollars but for your health you
know how much is enough it's a lot of
[ __ ] money in the bank yeah depending
how you live right yeah question is you
can see more of that my prediction is as
we learn more so so so I was listening
to steep a speak at his that was the
present but I believe he was slurring
his words I think he had took a lot of
brain damage and I think he I've been
thin you know I know it's not popular
opinion but I said this to Rogen to I
said do you know any other
english-speaking fighter with after you
subtitles I've been around sleep aid
before he is UFC crazy strain once in
Denver he was not like that
how could just be maybe a broken jaw
whatever you want to say it is I would
assume that it's a good chance I would
say it's a good chance he took a
shitload of shots he got punched a lot
he's incredibly durable his brain got
[ __ ] rattled its what Brennan an hour
after he fought two hours after he
fought he had he was slurring he was he
had brain damage there his he was not
himself he was concussed so just last
year luck made 26 27 million dollars and
on this topic I believe we're gonna look
back on that steep a thing in ten years
as we learn more about this stuff and
we're gonna go
can you believe can you look at look at
all the signs look what he's doing this
is crazy
you think oughta get I think
people know I think it's gonna become
measurably I think it's gonna become
measurable I think we're gonna get more
information sheet faster we're gonna
we're just gonna know we're gonna see
look at all the signs and that was what
was going on and look at all the shots
he took and we're gonna see that the
human head can't take that that you are
gonna have repercussions yeah but we
know you you guys know it's bad for his
health right like we still wha yeah so
but I guarantee for your hasty pay
you're gonna have brain trauma CT a few
years from now but you know you're the
world champion the world I tell you can
say okay yes I'm yep and hopeful for
Steve all of them hopefully for Steve
Bay and I do believe this any way that
your brain can heal and you're bringing
it better there's no questions so if he
takes a lot of time off he's gonna be
fine he'll have a great life you know I
certainly I don't think it works that
way I hope it does he's had a career of
fighting and it doesn't work that way be
adhering that cuz I think he's awesome I
was telling running to that I don't
always felt that he had that weird kind
of like you know I'm telling you I
listen to that news conference I just
understand what the [ __ ] he was saying
and we may as well a lot of people
didn't understand yeah I didn't like it
but I went to like older interviews and
he kind of has that same thing but I
guess maybe it's a good idea right yeah
like sighs like hope you're right chin I
hope you're right and I hope I'm wrong
but even take ste pay out of it if you
talk to any of these fighters already
talked NFL guys okay you know you hear a
brain trauma right you even when they're
young dogs said yeah sign me up man
every single it's sometimes it's all
worth the squeeze I mean you know a
football on you you care your knees suck
and you know but you play pro football I
mean it's what you set out to do you
know I mean it's like telling a Navy
SEAL hey dude it's really dangerous yeah
yeah I could lose my legs yeah I think
the bigger argument is they should be
cut like so and relaxed when how steep a
he's 32 multitude champion heavyweight
some you know you could there's arguing
is the best headway at all time he's 37
mmm so he's eight years older than
Andrew Luck Andrew Luck probably has 30
times more money than he does like
Andrew Luck can't stop and we're like
yeah he's gonna be fine he's gonna live
a rich life well he's also a Stanford
graduate in it with an
a texture degree he's got you know what
mrs. D buzzers do read - yes deeply and
state you know sure it's not Stanford
but he's an educated man of quiet
fighter yeah I mean steep is gonna be
fine either way he's been a success all
the way through but I'm saying the
bigger argument CT brain trauma 100
percent has he taken would work hold on
what do you what do you think you're
watching of course my brains around of
course FCT no one's gonna do [ __ ] about
it everyone here is gonna keep watching
so whatever I got no but my fingers is
Andrew Luck he might have some injuries
and you might have a limp playing with
his kids but he's set for life yes steep
a is not that's the issue here whoever I
think who do you think has taken more
brain trauma steep a right Oh see bear
who the order Andrew Luck steep a 100
percent right yeah right because I mean
training just training Andrew Luck only
gets hit in the game right he gets hit
when he fake getting sparring out boring
and it's direct head trauma all the time
yeah
well then there's bleeding in with the
game yeah and then you fight Daniel
Cormier and take that kind of punishment
so my thing is this I'm a fan of contact
sports I don't think they should ever go
away I think people's may be allowed to
make the decision to do whatever they
want with their bodies I I think my
question is is we learn more about this
I think you're gonna see voluntarily you
might even see sanctioned you might even
see the state coming and saying you can
you can do this for seven years and
that's it because we have so much
overwhelming evidence of the price
you're gonna pay the other question
though is like you we've also seen there
are a lot of football players that
played for a long time and there's 65 or
70 you know I have a [ __ ] thing so
there is that - and I know one of the
leading the leading head trauma
specialists at UCLA and she was like
you'd be surprised there are a lot of
people fighters who are boxers who don't
have any cognitive issues but they have
motor skills issues so it all depends on
what you're doing you know I don't know
it's a it's a it's a it's a weird no
it's not good yeah we know getting hit
in the head it's not we do know now we I
mean before remember are you watching me
OC wise girl we didn't know yeah you see
one two three we thought that you can
recover but then now we know so everyone
that's in the UFC knows that that's
well in high school when you're going to
do it developing to me in middle school
even those kids were right I mean you're
tackling and hitting pretty hard right
yeah yeah yeah it isn't interesting yeah
the whole bigger issue was debate should
be set for life and he's not yeah great
do you have any idea what he made for
that fight is it secret
I can't imagine more than 4 million
after taxes that's 2 I doubt they'll
show it though
there's Fighter payouts I'm surprisingly
that high Brandon
four million I'm surprised that so it
said the says seven on 50,000 flat 500
for DC but they're getting bonuses yeah
four million that's that's me like just
when people know you're dealing he's not
set for your knots at MIT so flat fee so
he gets a flat fee of 800 or so 750
thousand DC gets a flat fee of five so
those flat fees though that's not
they're making more than that yeah paper
why because a bonus well they they have
certain things especially as champion
you get certain pay-per-view point but
with the ESPN deal I don't I don't know
man
no one's making life-changing money
anymore that's why I think one of the
reasons you didn't see you're not seeing
Connor rushing back in that's one of the
reasons I think you know I can see Nate
Diaz amaz ball fight for a while because
they're not gonna pay me what he's worth
I think that's why Brock Lesnar was like
oh no I'm good
that's the model and I can't make the
money up supposed to make me then I'm
out so I think that's why you're not
getting these real big pay-per-view
hitters back in the game yeah but I
killed the models change they there's no
way I'm gonna make why should I
Costa alright let's say even with
bonuses I bet Sabri Ola CSD pre-primary
two million people you've got paid 800
dollars a man other 1.2 and bonuses you
know you fight for a year before that
Cleveland goes ways but I'm gonna pee I
epi you want to live hard you want to
live clean you want to live optimized we
know there's one company that does not
compromise you know I'm saying you
wrapping right yeah happen we must be on
out the brain you don't you talking
about on it bro on everything yes dude
on it calm slash fight or a little alpha
brain little new mood maybe you want
some melatonin rather want to sleep
better yeah man how about some creatine
so we can get Jack city
how about shroom tech immune or how
about just shroom tech in general if you
want to work out extra how about a
little krill oil to get that skin right
literally everything you want including
exercise about fitness gear they got it
check you want some Star Wars
sonic kettlebells want balanced ropes
bags balls clubs maces how about you
need a training program we got that on
at six kettlebell on at six steel mace
they got it all streaming easy apparel
shirts shorts backpacks socks
performance gear audit comm slash
fighter 10% off get yourself
hey B there's a lot of tools out there
that track your heart rate they might do
a thing here or there maybe you're on a
bike like I am I'm like damn I'll burn
in a thousand calories I'm not yeah well
how about you think you're getting good
rest you think you're doing the things
right you think I good diet but you're
not really tracking it right you're not
tracking with the best device possible
you mean you talk about woop a lot
waveform this tool change the way people
track the fitness and optimize their
training it really is kind of amazing I
mean before I even knew about it you
were wearing it and I said you you were
you're comparing it to other I've had a
bunch of watches yeah and you said this
was the best by far the bed you were a
customer before you this this became
summer a coupe is a performance tool you
get a whoop strap which is a heartrate
monitor that measures your heart rate a
hundred times per second 24 hours for
that stuff 24/7
you can charge it while you want you
don't even take it off just put on the
little battery it charges it usually
lasts about five days mine last a little
longer so five days without a charge
yeah so what would measure like what am
I gonna do though your recovery look at
your heart rate it make sure you're
getting the right rest if you're not
zero your strain how well you're working
out it checks your resting heart rate
max heart rate calories burn the amount
of exertion you're putting out
throughout the day your sleep - all that
REM deep light it does all that man it
provides all these insights down to the
nitty gritty and you got to get the new
woop 3.0 strapped that's what you need
to do go to whoop go to whoop comm whoop
there it is WH o Oh Pete calm use the
code fighter at checkout save $30 to
optimize the way you train again that's
woop comm promo code fighter for $30 off
the way you got to do it right to track
your train and get to shred Sadie treads
this whoa what's this chain
there's a new Rams rookie I'm supposed
to give out
yeah I saw a thing on him on Fox Sports
ditch tank him growing up his mom super
Chinese and then his dad the white boy
to her neck pounds six-foot stud super
stud speed all walk back 12 little low
monster plays for the Rams
I know but take it easy with your Asian
Mike trying to prove that you can play
okay Hines Ward - yeah I got it
yeah that's too even anyway there are
others name another one now there are
other half patient there's not players
harps there's there's that Gwynn there's
a good-looking guy the he's half black
and half asian half Korean don't talk
about in what sport
he's football NFL they're all mocking of
the Ravens safety don't look four years
ago yeah that guy that guy okay so we
got five in the history on that fella
it's kind of a big deal man have a half
a Chinese dude playing though yeah he's
Japanese Chinese Heinz worth grinds
Ward's the best his mom was uh Korea
yeah this guy that's good will
that's a good but he's retired now that
was a while ago Chet but still yeah but
to the this is proving my point
man wow that's a great that's a great
combination that's a good yeah he's
super attractive I don't know what he's
doing now but Hines Ward number one then
I guess you got Dimps remember that
kicker yeah oh yeah he's Korean see
right okay so it's done the vanishing
there's it's slim the vanishing yeah
this kid story was interesting because
you know he's the cheese Basie
especially for a normal kid like he's
Chinese yeah and then he's this baller
at football he got drafted by the LA
Rams and he's first team all pac-12 for
three years in a row that's really yeah
that's a Chinese maybe it's not a real
mom now here's the thing is there any
hate Chinese people that's not a big
deal
like there's a lot of sheet the Chinese
government but wait can I ask you this
what is there any full-blooded Asian in
the NFL well no I would have missed them
both but you said before dad no in was
probably the only one or a full
Vietnamese is he for Vietnamese dad
knowing him I don't know I think it's
always white it's mom Korean what it's
mom Chinese bro okay Chinese probably by
way of that Gwen I don't know I think
you had some white in him bro that's
pretty now he looks well that's that
said that new grin is a ways yeah if
enemies type in dagwon uh Bob east mom
and dad parents that's a beast he was
very good
I think retire kids concussions he had a
white wife riding a white girl I don't
know if that's his me he was a coach at
exam two maybe like a sister yeah cousin
it's thick fella uh yeah he was very
good man he's a stud it takes a member
of that I don't know if you won the
buckets but he's up for it i linebacker
huh
either way not a lot of Asians in
football you know that's the point of
this story yeah yeah mm-hmm that'd be
tough Wow grew up in Texas agent but he
was a there's a lot I agents in Texas
what's up there's a lot of agents in
Texas really a lot of enemies vietnamese
yea Vietnamese Alaia Houston Wow
he's the first hit nummies to play in
the NFL cool hold up you once said you
grew up part agent part Caucasian scroll
down do you know identify more as I know
I'm full blood oh he is full-blooded
yeah I believe that I'm awesome American
ok yeah oh he's funny he's full-blooded
Wow it's pretty impressive
there's more impressive than homeboy
with the white dad yeah have these what
else you got so this 19 year old woman
was at a drive-through chick-fil-a when
another
woman try to get in front of her and
what she ended up doing was she sped up
and stopped the other car from
proceeding she got out of the car
started to argue with the woman who was
in the other car trying to cut her off
she eventually started to hit the woman
the woman got out of her car it appeared
that she was pregnant they continued to
fight and this 19 year old woman ended
up kicking her in the stomach holy [ __ ]
they ended up stopped fighting after a
couple minutes she got back in her car
and continued to wait in line so the
pregnant woman called the police and by
the time the police officers got there
she was still waiting in line and she
got arrested Jesus Christ man I'll for
chick-fil-a it is delicious
sound video no interview no video have
you guys tried the popeyes chicken
sandwich my brother would you talk to
Jay about it no but I can't wait I mean
listen how fat my brother Jay is
although he's losing weight too but I
was his cheat day he said he went to
chick-fil-a for lunch then drove home
went to [ __ ] Popeyes and bought the
chicken sandwich to compare the two
that's right which is better he said
Popeyes yeah and I responded back you're
dead to me that's how much I love
chick-fil-a no I can't believe neither
of you have tried it I want it right now
no idea we're talking prior to bring it
in I'm actually you can't have it done
I've actually had both I'll get up no
you haven't Brian no just came and I
always never had Popeyes because I went
to college down in DC so it just came
out right sounds just came out Frank
come back you're old
no please come back please come back I'm
sorry I'll be younger
Brandon I'll be younger I'll be huh okay
okay take it easy
oh no I've actually had Paul I went to
school in DC in 1914 okay now
Popeyes just create a [ __ ] chicken
hey man I'm sorry
God i I'm sorry dude
oh no this is my bit well I've actually
had both no you know I hate China yeah
yeah we all have two pickles on it yes
man to come with pickles you wow that
looks there's no way this is better than
chick-fil-a dude I'm no - that looks
super tasty that's the word that is very
it's better than everything I'll [ __ ]
go get it now there's like who should
maybe should bring it on Wednesday I was
thinking of bringing it in
yeah but it's got to be hot that's
another thing I just get it I'll be so
funny okay
I've had chick-fil-a cold or hot
delicious oh we had to try that that
Burger King burger that had been made
like six days ago yeah I did taste I
play abroad where we had bird king of
the sponsors I was like how many burking
you I - I eat the [ __ ] out of his like
alright we're gonna be more Marshall
good person I guess that's [ __ ] away
right here fat ass - that's a real
comparison I don't give a [ __ ] do
chick-fil-a is so don't gotta make me
answer chick-fil-a is they they have a
giant shop they have a giant restaurant
in the arena in Atlanta they're not even
open on Sundays Sunday [ __ ] they're
religious yeah get over that there ya
know I take the lord's day off bro they
take mouths at Popeye's Chicken
Challenge looks pretty good or he can't
believe neither one of you had it we
could have [ __ ] you're on a plan for
Wednesday we could do Wednesday but what
we should do is have a chick-fil-a and a
Popeyes and then we all judge which
one's the best but just get it right
away I know it's gonna be tough well the
closest Popeyes is about seven and a
half miles away so it's not gonna be
that fresh listen I don't need it I
don't need it that fresh you taste a
good family also does pop I do fries do
you have the waffle cut fries you know
seasoned fries not wall right cut though
come on Brendan yeah but now that are
good it looks so good
yeah but that like first of all I know
the doc
right that's some kids picture how about
here again that's them [ __ ] on
chick-fil-a my price everybody knows
chick-fil-a does the best that bun does
look [ __ ] fresh though yeah and they
said it's like a cucumber type of pickle
you know like pickles are usually pickle
but it's like fresher like a cucumber uh
yeah I can't believe how we've had it
what do you been doing this I saw it I
saw this that I had to make a challenge
at home because I wanted to eat
something close to ya I didn't want to
add rival I heard is that there's like
they're running out in certain places
there's the lines are like alone or you
know that chickens and coachup what they
don't have the chicken sandwich on there
I try Oh type move cat because that's
what I would have done uh yeah I just
got keto breading to make chicken
sandwiches by the way they make that a
flower or something almonds all our dude
almonds coconut flour no choice just use
regular flour they can't the keto Adam
God oh you'd be surprised dude I've
actually a papaya salad for his school
in DC we have 1944 and Skye damn it yeah
man
we've all had fought by since everyone's
younger okay I don't know man down
always how I was younger god
I was thinking about if I was younger
the number of girls I would have avoided
mm-hmm I would have run away from the
date that say crow what else you guys
got let's see here
damn it where we are Kent what's the
next one this one oh okay so why woman
woke up one day and she felt like there
was something odd going on in her ear
and she assumed that it was just water
being stuck there he was bothering her
so much that she ended up going to a
doctor as the doctor went and examined
her ear she then said wait right here
I'm gonna have to call other people to
help she didn't tell the woman what it
was initially but as more doctors came
in to help her they told her you have a
spider stuck in your ear it turned out
that the spider was a venomous brown
spider brown recluse button hmm they're
really bad
it didn't bite her and they got it out
without killing the spider and she was a
bit in the process but now she says that
she can only sleep with earplugs yeah
wait how'd they get the spider without
abiding Maddie I don't know yeah grab
it's gonna [ __ ] bite that's [ __ ]
nuts
she was so lucky it doesn't mind us does
not happen more rags apparently is
really good deterrent to bugs which is
one of the reasons you have wax but if
you look at the way the African tribe
and Kenya sleeps they sleep with their
heads off the ground for exactly that
reason because ants will get in your ear
have you seen that will they sleep on
the ground the dirt no they sleep they
falsely in huts with their heads propped
on one's shoulder like been hut though I
just outsider and that's it's [ __ ]
yeah but you're sleeping on the ground
I'm saying for like American faces
Kresna happen more in certain parts of
the world you've got to be careful with
ants apparently we'll get in your ear
Jesus because here fine right that's
show show them sleeping on the ground
I'm like it's so crazy there's this is
it Kenyan yeah there's a tribe called
the [ __ ] that OSA well son I've been any
truck also it doesn't matter chin no I'm
no no sleeping right sleeping at Canyon
try and just put African tribal African
sleep it's definitely not African
sleeping oh wow wow like on the left
there be careful man may have a lion
will be keeping I can you describe
sleeping on ground oh yeah Dan that's
crazy if I stay upright dude Wow
hopefully get ours home there you go
he's propped up by something yeah so you
don't keep your [ __ ] ear on the
ground cuz otherwise I can't so there
you go
alright feels but also
you're gonna sleep out in the wilderness
okay that pillow
that's a hell are you comfortable you
want this a doorknob God for the back
your head I'd rather deal with that than
the spiders though all right yeah man
good luck out there what does he get is
this it yes okay so a 74 year old man
met a 53 year old man on a fetish site
where they both had fetishes in turn in
regards to castration the 53 year old
wanted to be castrated by the 74 year
old man and the 74 year old man says
that he was raised on a farm and he had
to castrate a lot of animals he actually
castrated one of his own testicles and
so he's done this in the past but they
had to call police because he started
the met the 54 year old man start to
bleed out and he didn't know what to do
so they came to this man's home and he
led them to the bedroom where the 53
year old was lying down he was losing a
lot of blood and he was rushed to the
hospital
luckily he survived but now the 74 year
old is in prison why he's just doing
something homeboy wanna he's just
cutting his also ha I believe he was
arrested for malpractice
inner-city was a doctor true Jesus here
trying to perform it in a local motel
room van res wake or whatever the foot
van allegedly has met one week earlier
and tried to perform the castration a
local motel the man became too aroused
while his penis was being sanitized and
according to the rest report yeah yeah
that's uh yeah there's some weird weird
weird dudes people are like who do you
into I like I mean ultimately I'd like
to have my balls removed by an old man
to talk about specific how about the old
man trying to convince them they could
do it yeah like I did on a few cows
growing up man cleaned his [ __ ] off and
I get your heart if that's your thing
that I get you going yeah I know a
[ __ ] friend of mine who's gay and
really good-looking and he likes old men
he's turned on by guys who look like
John McCain and I'm not joking
and I was like explain this to me please
without that do that oh yeah my friend's
wife watches granny porn she like she
market he caught her watching he looked
at her and she was looking at grandpa
like old men I mean a great hair with
young girls she was into it he was like
what's going on that's weird
yeah it all does she old is she she's
hot and she's a young Wow
yeah in her 30s interesting what else
you guys got boom so Robert DeNiro's
company is now suing a former employee
for six million dollars cuz as she she
used to be his former assistant she then
got promoted and when she got promoted
she started coming into the office and
not really doing much a lot of people
actually saw her watching reruns of
different shows like The Office and
Parks and Rec and friends while she was
at work when they found out that she was
embezzling money from the company they
confronted her she resigned and now
she's being sued oh so Jim the promise
she was embezzling money yeah Jesus
Christ it's just funny that's why she's
getting sued for 6 million 6 million
there's they're suing her for 6 million
right now is that how much she stole
them no they're reporting that it's
300,000 mmm that stuff right Wow over
the two year period Ronson made a bunch
of charges at a restaurant a lot of uber
all ready to grant on uber zantac just
got paid to watch a bunch of [ __ ]
they're gonna pay it all back
let's take a look oh you sent me this
last week did I yeah the use of gas
stations sexual enhancement pills in
baseball is so prevalent the MLB sent
out a memo warning player set there use
could lead to positive PD tests at least
two players have claim this year what
are you guys what do you guys really
think
I don't think they're taking [ __ ] from
the gas yeah I think they're testing hot
for peds and blaming it just like John
did mm-hmm yeah me too I believe that
most of them are doing some kind of a PD
I don't think it's the date yeah same
here goes on it's put also it's baseball
let him take their with ya you guys
remember the Taylor Taylor Swift
controversy right yeah yeah why big
machine records model or master huh
well after reading more about it it did
seem like she's kind of a kind of a cat
person she's like a bad person it seems
like she like she knew it or something
from when you read all the different
accounts from all people that no Scooter
Braun and her it's most likely she was
just mean you know a [ __ ] or whatever
anyways turns out that in 2020 she can
legally record her songs again so she's
planning on recording to own all of them
yeah all the same songs over again and
put him up Wow
so then that would devalue Scooter Braun
of course like because you know you want
to buy the new stuff that she recorded
right yeah sure yeah Wow
type move by Taylor Swift big-time
that's a lot of work to most yet the
[ __ ] lot of work a lot of work so I want
to do that really yeah I'm recording
some of my old stuff just to put out on
YouTube on my terms
like my old bits yeah well I don't own
it I sold it you know when I sold it to
Showtime but you get it do you yeah but
the company owns it they've bought it
but it's fine I mean I'm just gonna I
just want to put some of it out now cuz
there are old bits that I like a lot you
know
you just have them live on YouTube I
could do it with the old stuff but it's
that's different than what they're doing
yeah someone owns their [ __ ] and she's
just gonna rerecord our songs mm-hmm
yeah do that though if they owns you
know the contract whatever that any
point you're Tama is something different
yeah it also depends on their contracts
because they didn't foresee streaming to
be something that people would use more
than buying actual CDs or records or
even buying the music off of iTunes so
now a lot of people are going back to
rerecord their songs their kind
Jojo was bat was pretty big back in the
day and she's releasing all of her music
that used to be owned by her prior
record label time ooh hmm
Jojo yeah beautiful girl her audience is
not a dick you --less savages yeah
ridiculous her and Beyonce's are like
talk it's also my daughter's yeah he
can't flush their their mind nope she's
right no matter what to them always
right pretty cool I saw this there's a
movie called bombshell coming out and
it's about the whole Fox drama you know
the sexual allegations yeah yeah
Showtime right did this though do they
mmm-hmm and the dude from gladiator
what's the name Russell Crowe's it'll
play duh mhm Marat trails well I guess
this is more focused on the three women
and I just saw this woman do you guys
know who this is family right
oh no no the home girl from Siena right
no so this is the actress playing
playing on Megan Kelly yeah that's right
Megan Kelly she damn sure this is
Charlize Theron how crazy is that there
was a little bit of Charlize doing out
there I thought bacon Kelly what
happened to her
she'd have to show you how Good Morning
America it just wasn't doing wrong they
got rid of her dude she can [ __ ]
report these nuts in her mouth
she is attractive dude that Margot
Robbie yeah yes but you can't recognize
or at least I couldn't recognize
Charlize wow she looks very similar to
it yeah so I think now they're doing in
Hollywood they're actually putting on
you know little bits of prosthetic
facial makeup like to structure it what
I'm think of Robert Murdock no no but
that was the thing Showtime did with
Russell okay then they look so much like
them so they're putting some sort of
filler stuff in their faces right
because that doesn't look like Nicole
Kidman no perfectly right looks like it
might be prosthetic prosthetic
I've been doing that for a hot second
check different no I'm just gonna paint
with a [ __ ] Batman Forever think you
know usually nose is really like that
usually for like actual characters for
real see a really cool trailer yeah dude
what happened
Kelly oh but Alex don't but yeah they
don't usually do it for actual people
they're portraying right just depends
well did you see monster Charlize Theron
she was they didn't change your face
she's just like what's never ever seen
that gonna change your eyebrows and
stuff my best moments maybe ever in my
opinion in motion picture history that's
so aggressive I know your friend
directed it no I think I said I said it
when I saw it and I said today that's
the weapon tell you though let's find
out what happened to her man she was all
over she might be taking a break I'm
using this break and entertainment
that means retired Brian so she has a
reporter can't have brakes
yeah brakes you're forced to take it
she's probably being courted there you
go fishy out of NBC this isn't January
though see because she left Fox in went
to ABC she lasted 18 months she got him
she uh the parties have resolved their
differences and kill he's no longer
employee of NBC they had issues though
scroll up chin up yeah right there man
Kelly you enjoyed the state crap Fox and
shyster little rake you month MVC
comfort of Germany part ways after
Shuster country by defend the use of
blackface on Halloween costumer that one
but the problem is now if you're an
opinion journalist you can't be an
objective journalist because you have to
speak to your base you have to speak to
your viewers and you check your ratings
every [ __ ] ten minutes so whoa scroll
in the middle one bro right now she's on
vacation but still working hard on her
fit April
being in this blue bikini say what you
want about megyn kelly these photos
change she's in phenomenal shape yeah it
reminds me of someone now who someone
you guys know yes people have said what
they what I'll tell you afterwards it's
it rhyme with there are breeze
oh you can't you excite Whitney Miller
yeah kind of I like it Whitney Miller
yeah all right it just wasn't a
different audience trying to go a little
broader it didn't really work but that's
not to say that making killing won't be
successful what she goes back to be
interesting she's in shape now would you
say you lost all of your body but about
the state more than this Chinese thing
about stairs that's all
oh God keep going eight of everything
everything dude all right
this dude was caught sleeping as Tesla
have you ever oh yeah never my prop but
who cares first of all no don't know
what they're for not really try cuz your
hands have to be on the wheel so it'll
happen is no they don't look okay
that's the block no I'll have them they
do because well I'll give you a warning
and then I'll give you another one if
you've known us two warnings you're you
cannot you can no longer have
self-driving it'll just shut off for
that Finan ride it goes dudes we
wouldn't no longer you see you have to
have your hands no wheel yeah I mean so
I did a Tesla uber once and the guy was
showing us how it you know took his
hands off the wheel and it started going
like he had to put it back on it's got
50 cameras but but at the same time I
don't trust it and I rarely use it all I
was traffic I use it I went trust and I
can sleep in yeah and bummer - bummer
traffic I just like that not gonna sit
but yeah I saw this this is on this is
22 is this I'll play it for you real
quick
this dude's stood snoozing hard right so
he's just knocked out hands arms crossed
my wife and I with our five-year-old boy
we're driving into Southern California
on the five and traffic was really
moving really well how's it for sanction
huh can you imagine me that guy with the
news is like so tell us how you feel
like yeah no problem so the thing is I
was on high now like it
tourists nod but that guy so what
happens it you can see he gets woken up
though yeah you could tell you could
tell my agent guy right he's out for a
while why is his dashboard though last
week he was clearly asleep Clint Olivier
says traffic was moving at speeds of up
to 75 people so anyways this guy was
caught on camera right yeah and it turns
out someone else caught him it has to be
the same guy like before not this guy
here drivers have been caught on camera
apparently asleep at the wheel this
video captured on a Nellie watch the job
waited about six months ago looks just
the same dude what he does bro that's
why bought the Tesla scene sleep the
same guy definitely the same guy poured
it because the driver woke up and took
control of you know well no he wasn't
impact Oh catnap I think was that hey
grab [ __ ]
interesting that's hilarious it's gonna
have a retina scan you'll see as soon as
your eyes closed for too long it's gonna
know you get to the point where you or
you can sleep yourself driving that's
what they're trying to do now I'm pretty
sure they could do it but I just don't
trust it well they tried that one it
like wrecked into the wall yeah the Sun
yes the side of a truck a white truck
for the son of the problem that's
working out there well that's a guy on
Rogan who's the leading scientist on us
he goes no not if when it malfunctions
keep your hands on the wheel yeah but
they get to a point where it's good to
go it's just you don't wanna be the one
to try it yeah a computer will drive
better than a human there's no question
its yeah but I mean those little
glitches I'm just not any years what
else yet this was the last week I'm sure
you guys already saw this but Ronda
Rousey's finger what have been doing she
was filming the 9-1-1 show on fox i
think it is and then a boat door slammed
into her she thought as she was fine so
she finished the scene but check out how
bad our hand is i'll show you right here
how crazy is that that's a serious what
happens Travis - I think that might be
makeup
damn feeling so sad but it's fine now no
I'm sure they just yeah yeah put it back
together it looked like it just like the
bone they rip off just the skin so they
just put back down and sewed it but look
it's it's above yeah it's your finger
that looks like a broken finger yeah
girl though oh all right the last ones
not that great but I just saw something
interesting Chris Brown
I guess he's having a son with this girl
oh they're back together or they just
hooked up hey
this her name is a Micah Harris she's
the Harris grab yeah Karrueche know so
check it out hey look I'd an apple
that's him in Karrueche right they look
such a diamond she's it look at that
girl but then look at the girl he has a
baby with how crazy is that she look
like the same girl yeah it was hot as
[ __ ] he's gotta type hot as [ __ ]
but they look like both half asian half
black well great combo let me some more
features of her whoa so he's having a
baby with her yeah Wow well together
anymore though so yeah really they're
just having the baby but okay not
necessarily together well here he has a
girl with a little bit - she looks so
much like cushy they do but not so nice
here but here for sure is that Karrueche
no that's her amico and this is crew
chief ah who cheese a little prettier
yeah she's like the Chrysler 300c and
the food she's like the real phantom you
know I'm saying yeah how do you think
they look similar till they're
side-by-side
yep that's what I say do you me a pop
like chicken sandwich no I don't want to
every rings don't
Wow everybody everybody by the way
thanks for the [ __ ] nickname rings a
thousand [ __ ] yes
hey ring yeah guys just like he hey ring
goddammit well mean the rinks Army in
North Cal this Saturday man shows almost
sold out one show one night only me and
Brian Allen bragger at cold country
casino in Oroville California audio I'm
going don't worry about that
this Wednesday this Wednesday come see
me Brendan Schaub Bill Bergquist Illya
and a couple of other surprise guests at
the Laugh Factory
starting in 9:45 all proceeds go to a
very good charity please come out eat a
whole one oh we do need a host I think I
may have work maybe I think Michael and
no cheese is gonna do it let me see but
yeah we can do it Derek is great well
not you said Michael ah it's too late no
dear I might put maybe I put Mike on
just as a comic let's see what happens
we'll talk we'll see yeah I've got to
see who's I got to see who else what
other heavy major stadium comic is
coming up I'll say we could have some
very big surprises either way laugh
factory Wednesday all right oh wait one
more date for me Tampa yes improv Tampa
improv the 27th and 28th of September I
am going to be there what hotel do I
stay at do you where did you stay in
Thai forget man your brother won't
I'm at the ice house September 12th
that's pasady nice house shopping
friends Houston improv September 22 the
21st
I'm in Denver economy work September 26
through the 28th then tickets for
Pittsburgh and Philly in October just
one on sale t fat K dr. Holm that it be
yep sure it's the fun kid Wow